We'd like to analyze a
physics problem called
the rocket problem, in which
we have a continuous mass
transfer.
Let's see what we mean by that.
Let's consider a
rocket launching.
So here's a classic example of
a rocket that's launching off
in a gravitational field.
As a rocket starts at rest,
it starts to burn fuel,
and ejects the fuel backwards.
And as the ejected
fuel backwards
is producing a thrust on the
rocket-- and you can see,
as the rocket starts
to rise-- it's
starting to accelerate upwards
as fuel is ejected backwards.
Now, this process goes on
for some time interval.
And a lot of fuel
is ejected backwards
during that time interval.
In this particular case, we
could analyze the situation
from the ground
frame of the rocket--
frame of the earth--
and the fuel is
ejected backwards
relative to the rocket,
rocket moves up forward.
So how do we analyze
this situation?
If we just looked at the rocket
when the rocket initially
launched, the mass of the rocket
is the dry mass of the rocket
plus all the fuel in there.
It's at rest.
In a state much later on,
the mass of the rocket
has decreased and the
speed has increased.
But we can't just compare this
initial to this final state,
because throughout
this process, there
was a continuous mass transfer.
Fuel was ejected backwards.
So how do we analyze these types
of continuous mass transfer
problems?
And the key is, again,
identifying states.
So, for a continuous
mass transfer problem,
we always have to choose
a reference frame.
So here, in our example,
we were choosing
the ground frame of the earth.
And then, we want to
identify two states.
We don't want to identify the
initial and the final states.
We want to pick two arbitrary
states that are separated
by a small time interval.
So we can take a
state at time t.
And then our second state occurs
at a small time afterwards,
time t plus delta t.
And what we want to do is now
represent the state changes
by momentum diagrams.
And that will lead us to a
differential equation, which
is called the rocket equation.
And that's how we'll analyze
all continuous mass transfer
problems.
In applying the
momentum principle,
our first thing is just to
choose a reference frame.
So in our example,
we're going to choose
the ground frame of the
earth as a reference frame.
Now, the next step is the
key to these processes.
Instead of choosing some initial
state where the rocket is
at rest and some final
state much later on,
we want to choose
two states that
are separated by a small
time interval, delta t.
So our first state, at time t.
And our second state, we
choose at time t plus delta t.
Now, the next step
is that we have
to identify what is our system.
And so in this
case, our system is
going to be the mass of
the rocket at time t.
That mass is the dry
mass of the rocket
plus all the fuel that's
still in the rocket at time t.
And this mass will stay the
same between times t and t
plus delta t, even
though some of the mass
has been ejected downward.
So our next step is to look
at that mass conservation
of the system.